you were just in london doing press the
foreign press uh for the movie horrible
bosses too right what's that like doing
when you do the foreign press i've
always found that to be a little weird
you're navigating a lot of accents uh we
had this one a chilean woman who kept
referring it to us uh her country as
tilley and i was thinking oh gosh i
never realized it was pronounced tilley
so you know i would do the things can
you say hi like hello people of chile
and then
afterwards realizing
did she just have a lisp
and it looks like you're making and now
now i'm just uh rubbing it in so cause
it's pretty but how are you supposed to
know i mean that's the thing is what if
there's a small island called tillet
yeah i'm sorry i think you mean chile
and she's like i do not mean chile no
the island of chile
[Laughter]
what's the most common question you got
from the foreign press oh all they care
about is jennifer anderson right because
jennifer anderson in the movie with you
as she was in horrible buses once yes
and they just want to know about
jennifer aniston she's fabulous again
but they're all like um now in in the
movie does she
will she makes some kind of love to you
uh
does she touch you how many times where
does she touch you uh you know like she
doesn't touch me uh it's just a movie
like but outside of the movie do brush
against her or
are you sure this guy was a journalist
yeah
he might have
i think over there any creep can wander
in uh yes yes uh how was it christoph
vaults yeah if you call him waltz i say
vault
i call him sir and just try to avoid it
you know um uh how is working with
christophe waltz well i'm terrified of
the germans uh you know um so
what is austrian yeah oh he's austria
yeah yeah yeah like hitler
[Laughter]
right right yeah yeah so it's okay yeah
the guy's amazing but you really can't
which guy's amazing uh hitler
i gotta be really clear about i'm trying
to help you out finally here to get my
point across
uh yeah no thank you yeah i'm just
trying to straighten it out for you
because he just said hitler when you
went the guy's amazing that's right
chris got vaults very misunderstood
no christophe wallace uh nothing like
hitler yeah let's take ourselves out of
this hole this uh um uh you know but you
can't tell if he's joking or if he's
serious which is something that happens
with the accent the accent i think you
know like he'll kind of raise his chin
and be like i suppose that was a good
take
you're like
is that a joke are you serious
moving on then i guess
you know so so you don't know if he's
being incredibly sarcastic yeah or just
saying i think that was you know a good
take yeah he's either positive or he's
convinced that
bateman and sedakis and i really stink
so i was like
fine let's go on i suppose
now you mentioned the other guy you did
some stunt driving in the movie with
jason sedakis you know yeah not so much
i didn't do so much stunt driving but we
did we were in a few contraptions we we
actually were uh in this car that was up
on a stand about 30 feet high in the air
and it was a funny thing uh the the sort
of safety guy i don't know what his job
was comes buzzing up on a big crane
leans in the wind and goes
car's going to tip over 90 degrees
[Music]
that's the only thing
of it yeah that's the first rehearing
event and bateman is freaking out and
without missing a beat he goes i've had
longer
safety meetings about holding a sparkler
uh but tipped over we were fine you know
worked out bumped against the windshield
a little bit but uh no one died no one
died that's the important thing yeah and
you've gotten uh hurt doing sonny and
philadelphia you've done stunts on that
show i have because talk about like uh
low rent uh safety guys yeah um
i mean i i remember one time diving into
the marina here at long beach and
literally swimming through motor oil and
like past like
condoms and like
coming out of the water and like people
being like uh
should we put some soap in your ears
like yeah i guess that'll do it let's go
for take two
i did that once they had me jump into
the east river when i was doing the late
night show from a pier at night the east
river and talk about innis wearing a
full suit and i go down and then i come
back up again and they're all looking
and they said can we do it again
no i don't want to do it again no i did
it three times uh
yeah physically i'm 88 years old